[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos de cómo puede la
unióneuropea desconectarse del gas y del
petróleo y del carbón de rúsia cuanto a
una gran parte del continente necesita a
rusia para abastecerse ha sido la guerra
de ucrania el gran despertar para europa
lo analizamos con nuestros invitados
pero antes vemos qué es lo que ocurre
exactamente con la dependencia
energética que mantiene europa con rusia
el 40 por ciento del gas con el que se
abastece la unión europea proviene de
rusia sin embargo la dependencia de los
países varía mientras en hungría su
dependencia es casi del 100% y la
alemania el 50% en españa es sólo el 10%
la invasión a ucrania ha provocado que
la unión europea empieza a plantear
medidas para tratar de prescindir del
combustible ruso el dinero que pagan los
países europeos a rusia por su gas
alcanza los 800 millones de euros
diarios
un dinero que al final llega a las arcas
de blind footing y que les sirve para
financiar la guerra la comisión europea
propuso recientemente que antes de que
se acabe el año se reduzcan dos tercios
la importación del gas del país vecino
el objetivo es que en cinco años la
dependencia sea cero un objetivo tanto a
corto como a mediano plazo muy ambicioso
porque se tendrá que aumentar la
importación de gas natural licuado desde
eeuu y catar y sobre todo apostar
definitivamente por las energías
renovables aún así muchos países temen
los enormes costes que puede provocar
esta transición la decisión puede ser
también muy difícil porque encarecerá la
energía en un aumento con la inflación
desbocada y puede provocar más pobreza
en los hogares así como un incremento
del descontento social no obstante los
gobiernos europeos creen que ahora es
momento de actuar o de lo contrario lo
mantendrán para siempre
y para entender un poco cuáles son las
posibles medidas y cuál es la situación
contamos con arnés urtasún del grupo de
los verdes bienvenido a arnés gracias y
con nicolás gonzález casares del grupo
socialdemócrata bienvenido a nicolás
todos muchas gracias a los dos por estar
aquí me gustaría empezar precisamente
con nicolás con nicolás los países de la
unión europea se han comprometido a
reducir aproximadamente unos dos tercios
la dependencia del gas ruso este mismo
año es esto posible bueno debe ser
posible porque si se han comprometido
deben hacerlo pero va a ser difícil
lograrlo va a requerir muchos esfuerzos
y buscar gas que no sea ruso en buena
parte del mundo creo que ya se está
haciendo ya previamente a la invasión ya
se estaba haciendo este este trabajo
pero va a ser algo un esfuerzo que va a
requerir no sólo buscar gas sino también
ver cómo economizar el consumo de gas
precisamente comentabas lo de que ya se
había empezado a reducir esta
dependencia del gas ruso ya desde la
invasión de la península de crimea en
2014 pero la dependencia se ha mantenido
aproximadamente a un 40 por ciento la
unión europea ha pecado de ingenua con
rusia
yo creo que las decisiones en materia
energética y particularmente de alemania
han sido profundamente erróneas en los
últimos años creo que la angela merkel
ha puesto en una situación de
dependencia de geopolítica alemana en
relación con rusia totalmente
inexplicable no y que estuviéramos
discutiendo aún hace tan solo pocas
semanas y el north stream 2 debía seguir
adelante parecía una auténtica
barbaridad el gobierno alemán ha puesto
en marcha ahora un un plan de para salir
rápidamente el
vice-canciller robert huff presentó
precisamente hace un hace un par de días
la posibilidad de que se dejara ya este
mismo año que alemania dejará de
importar tanto carbón como petróleo
porque no sólo es gas también es
carbón y petro este mismo año y una
perspectiva 2024 para el gas no que yo
creo que debemos tratar de acelerar lo
máximo posible y eso pasa
fundamentalmente por un despliegue más
rápido y mejor de las energías
renovables que van a requerir mucha
financiación y este también son los
grandes debates que vamos a tener aquí
en los próximos meses si vamos a tener
que poner en marcha nuevos instrumentos
europeos para acelerar esa transición
ecológica
los nuevos instrumentos por ejemplo como
la emisión de deuda bueno yo creo que se
está empezando a hablar de la
posibilidad de hacer un segundo plan de
recuperación específicamente para cerrar
la transición ecológica eso
evidentemente el debate está aún muy muy
en los inicios pero yo creo que había
habido varios varios grupos aquí que
hemos empujado en esa dirección también
porque sabemos que el margen fiscal de
los países con la mano con la inflación
disparada y con las decisiones que pueda
tomar el bc pues serán más reducidos y
una vez más europa va a necesitar hacer
una probablemente volver a hacer una
gran emisión de deuda como el fondo de
recuperación para acelerar esa
transición y yo desde luego creo que esa
es una buena una buena medida y que
habría que apostar por ello
nicolás aprovechando la visita de joe
biden del presente eeuu aquí a bruselas
la unión europea y eeuu firmaron un
acuerdo para aumentar la exportación de
un 68 por ciento del gas natural licuado
proveniente de eeuu estamos hablando de
un gas que es mucho más caro hay que
transportarlo hay que convertirlo
es un caso natural liquado una de las
mejores opciones a corto plazo bueno no
es que sea una de las mejores opciones
es que probablemente es de la única que
tenemos para liberarnos de esa
dependencia porque como ha dicho ernest
hay un problema la gran dependencia
alemana y es ese juguete o por el gas
ruso durante años nos provocan que ahora
sea mucho más difícil cambiarlo si por
ejemplo alemania no tiene terminales de
gas natural licuado un tercio de ellos
están en la península ibérica para
españa así que puede ser una solución y
pues podemos ser también una solución
para el resto de europa a la hora de
compartir gas y yo creo que eso es algo
en lo que se debe trabajar los próximos
meses y años pero es cierto que ese gas
natural liquado pues es más porque hay
que transportarlo porque tiene son las
conversiones pero bueno es más caro
depende en qué situaciones porque en
estos momentos pues el gas ruso también
está muy caro porque es el que se está
importando está a unos precios
desorbitados derivados de las
consecuencias de la guerra por lo tanto
en estos momentos ese gas va a ser
necesario pero eso también nos provoca
dilemas en europa quiero decir este gas
proviene del fracking de la fractura
hidráulica algo que ecológicamente pues
no estamos haciendo europa porque
creemos que no debe hacerse nos sometan
a nuevas contradicciones por lo tanto yo
creo que sí que hay que acelerar el
proceso de instalación de más fuentes de
energía renovable hay que hacer un
despliegue rápido ser ambiciosos y
llevarlo a cabo de una manera acelerada
pero eso sí a la vez respetuosa con el
medio ambiente con el territorio y con
las personas que viven en ese territorio
precisamente me gustaría hacerles una
pregunta a los dos a este respecto
porque hay otras energías como la
nuclear que algunos países como francia
también bélgica anunciado que la va a
mantener
es un peligro ahora mismo la situación
que estamos viviendo ahora con el gas
para arreglar izar los objetivos
climáticos que algunos países digan es
que ahora tenemos un problema hay que
esperar aún
cambiar a ver yo creo que nosotros
nuestro objetivo es tener fuentes de
energía que no emitan co2 que sean
económicamente viables
y después que nos garanticen una cierta
seguridad nuestro ministro independencia
energética la nuclear no emite pero al
nuclear tiene el problema de los
residuos radioactivos que no está
resuelto es una energía carísima sólo
hay que ver el desvío presupuestario de
las nuevas centrales representadas por
francia que debían costar unos 45 mil
millones y vamos van por los 20 mil la
nueva central de flama móvil y en tercer
lugar la energía nuclear no nos
garantiza la soberanía energética porque
porque el uranio lo tenemos que importar
y de hecho sí que si cogemos la nuclear
española un tercio del uranio proviene
de rusia es decir que la energía nuclear
no es una fuente de energía ni segura ni
barata ni soberanía ni que nos dé esa
soberanía energética que queremos no por
lo tanto desde luego nosotros no estamos
de acuerdo en pensar que esa tenga que
ser la solución
nicolás bueno pues yo creo que en estos
momentos no debemos prescindir de ni un
solo electrón descarbonizado quiere
decir que lo que está en funcionamiento
yo creo que en estos momentos debe
seguir en funcionamiento para
garantizarnos que en este momento
tengamos una cierta autonomía pero
coincido en que pensar en nuevas
instalaciones nucleares que no sean para
sustituir algunas que ya están en
funcionamiento lo entiendo desde el
punto de vista de francia que tiene
mucha confianza en la energía nuclear
pero lo entiendo desde el punto de vista
de otros países pensar en ampliar
nuestra capacidad nuclear yo creo que en
el tiempo que se amplía capacidad
nuclear se desarrolla mucho más
renovable y en menor precio y aparte la
energía renovable además nos provee de
una electricidad más barata y sin duda
nada contaminante por lo tanto creo que
ese es el camino y el camino que debemos
seguir ya digo no prescindamos de ningún
electrón que no contamine que no
contamine desde el punto de vista del
co2 pero tengamos cuidado porque no
tenemos resuelto el asunto de los
residuos y debemos seguir trabajando
empujar las energías renovables no en
dedicar dinero a la energía nuclear
en la última cumbre de jefes de estado
de gobierno hemos visto que hay una
situación que divide que es la del
embargo del petróleo ruso es factible
este embargo
es factible asumiendo un coste alto es
así a mí no me parecería mal si el
gobierno alemán decidiera establecer ese
embargo y si sabemos que el gobierno
levante en un plan de contingencia
porque aunque no tome esa decisión en
cualquier momento puede ser vladimir
putin que decida cerrar el grifo con lo
cual ese plan de contingencia existe
costaría en términos de pippi de
crecimiento pues un coste sería
evidentemente significativo pero el
gobierno decide alemán decide hacer eso
a mí no me parecería mal pero en
cualquier caso lo que sí creo que sin
duda tiene que hacer el gobierno alemán
es acelerar esa transición y reducir esa
dependencia desde ese punto de vista el
plan presentado para terminar a carbón y
petróleo este mismo año y gas como muy
tarde en 2024 pues ya son avance en la
buena dirección
bueno pues yo lo que creo es que debemos
primero acelerar el rellenado de los
depósitos conseguir cuanto más gas sea
posible en menos tiempo mejor para
librarnos de la posibilidad de que se
corte el gas de una manera abrupta por
parte de rusia pero por otro lado creo
que si se podría hacer pero habría que
explicar las ciudadanías todos los
costes que conlleva estamos viendo
protestas en diferentes países por los
altos precios de los combustibles
tenemos que saber que si eso ocurre y si
se toma esa decisión por parte de
alemania yo creo que el resto del 27
debe apoyar fuertemente a alemania si
toma ese decisión pero todos siendo
conscientes y está agradando muy
claramente a la ciudadanía lo que va a
ocurrir durante unas semanas o meses que
va a ser una subida de los precios y en
algunos casos hasta puede haber
desabastecimiento porque no creo que
rusia permita que dejemos de comprar gas
pero le sigamos comprando gasoil o
carbón no sería una cosa extraña por lo
tanto yo creo que en cierta medida hay
que estar preparado con esos planes de
contingencia ir a la compra conjunta de
gas como ha defendido del gobierno
español
tan pronto como sea posible los
depósitos para pasar el próximo invierno
precisamente antes nicolás comentabas
que
españa podría utilizar sus capacidades
para transitar el gas natural licuado
que son los estaciones que además
también se podrían utilizar para el
hidrógeno verde es este el momento
definitivo que necesitaba a europa para
potenciar este tipo de tecnología
bueno yo creo que la
estamos hablando aquí sobre todo de qué
tipo de interconexiones tenemos que
tener y yo creo que es positivo aumentar
las interconexiones entre entre la
península el resto de europa y yo sigo
sin ver la necesidad de hacer
interconexiones de gas lo digo también
porque está en estos días lo del mityc
ante encima encima de la mesa como una
de las opciones entre otras cosas porque
yo sigo pensando que la prioridad debe
ser invertir el dinero en acelerar el
despliegue de las renovables sino en
construir seguir construyendo
infraestructuras fósiles además que la
construcción del mercat llevaría un
tiempo
y no sería operativo en los próximos
meses y por lo tanto eso no sería una
solución a la crisis que tenemos en el
corto no lo digo porque tu pregunta creo
que vamos relacionada con el tema del
mexicano yo ahora mismo no veo que ese
sea un producto necesaria
interconexiones eléctricas sí pero es
otra cuestión muchísimas gracias nicolás
de arnés nos hemos quedado ya sin tiempo
a ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de europa hoy gracias por ver
france24 en español
[Música]